hey guys remember when you were young
and you always had this feeling at the
back of your mind that you knew one day
you would be bestowed with the
superpower you want to get high what are
you doing
airbending shut up x-ray vision I
remember always feeling like on my 16th
birthday I would get this amazing
magical gift
it's like when you turn 13 and realize
there's no Hogwarts acceptance letter
coming for you
[Music]
this is really necessary I'm not gonna
lie I'm kind of angry you grow up
reading fantasy and science fiction only
to realize that as you grow into
adulthood nothing magical or special is
gonna happen to you other than like
average human the events like a newborn
baby and not to downplay the magic of
newborn babies babies are fucking
magical but if I had to choose between
telekinesis and a baby sometimes I can't
read science fiction because if it it
literally makes me angry what dance and
Gotham look I'm sorry look I'm so sorry